hello everyone and welcome back to the
1991 Linares series featuring Vasiliy
even shook now in my previous video I
told you that in the first seven rounds
before facing Anand in round eight he
defeated experiment Karpov were when in
fact he defeated also gotta calm skin
round four I misread the information on
chess Gamescom so sorry about that so
this is Round four
Evancho is playing against Gothic Kamsky
and the Kamsky well he's originally from
Russia but later he became an American
Grandmaster he was awarded the
Grandmaster title in 1990 so one year
prior to this event and well this is the
first tournament of this strength for
him so he didn't really do that well in
the tournament in the end he only had
two and a half points he got last place
but nevertheless I'm sure it was quite
an experience and this game his playing
against Vasily von Schuch Kamsky has the
white pieces and there are there are
very interesting things in the chess
world but here for example eventually
goes for the Marshall attacks so this is
this is something else completely so
let's see this game and well one one
legend of the Marshall attack it is said
that Frank Marshall actually invented
the Marshall attack some eight years
before he actually played it in the
tournament he was waiting to use it
against someone who is worthy and well
he for that someone he chose the great
cuban josé raúl capablanca and well
although even Capablanca met with this
attack for the first time over the board
it wasn't enough to defeat kappa blanka
Capablanca defended well and he won a
great brilliancy but this is the game
come scheme I took so let's see it
come ski plays efore we have E 5 Knight
to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 the
Royal opus a6 the Morphy defense Bishop
to a4 Knight to f6 castles Bishop to e7
now rook to e1 b5 this is all standard
theory Bishop to b3
eventual castles and we have c3
practically inviting black to go for the
marshal attack those who fear the
marshal attack will play something like
h3 here the anti martial variation but
Kamsky is young and while I'm sure he
wasn't afraid of event going for the
marshal attack so he played c3 and the
event took place d5 upon sacrifice but
the black acquires immense activity he
captures on d5 Knight captures on d5 and
now white grubs upon Knight captures on
e5 we have Knight captures on e5 and
rook captures on e5 and there are a lot
of options here for black in this game
event you've played pawn to c6 which is
which is an improvement on the game
martial versus couple kappa blanka
versus marshal but I will just show van
a1 variation where black responds wood
night with Knight to f6 as this is one
of my favorite variations and I won a
couple of games with white in this line
so d4 for white now Bishop to d6
I would an attack on the rook rook to e1
and now Knight to g4 going for h2 so h3
kicking the night and now Queen to h4
now the queen is threatening Queen
characters on f2 and after Queen to f3
black plays and Knight captures on f2
Queen captures an f2 and now black
thinks that he's winning
a great victory with Bishop to g3 now
attacking the Queen and the rook but
here all of his dreams crumble as White
has this beautiful resource of playing
Queen captures on f7 with check there is
no no good move here if you move the
King Queen wraps Rock is checkmate so
rook captures Queen and now rook to e8
is checkmate because this rook on f7 is
pinned from the bishop on b3 so here
just a fun line the show before the
actual game so after rook captures only
5 Avant you didn't go for Knight to f6
key one for c6 this is
improvement we have D for now Bishop to
d6 and Kamsky plays rook to e2 not going
for rook to e1 to go for some standard
Queen to h4 ideas so even though he was
young he was 17 years old here he was no
he was no stranger to the secrets of the
marshal attack Bishop to g4 now
attacking the rook and the Queen f3
Bishop to h5 and Bishop captures on d5
comes he gives up the bishop pair he
wants to grab that strong piece and d5
to maybe be able to preserve his extra
pawn seek after Sun d5 and we have night
the d2 comes he wants to develop this
night well either with b3 although after
b3 it's not really going anymore so
probably night to f12 e3 the wherever
will be possible but Ivana has a plan
for that f5 we have Queen to b3 now
attacking the d5 pawn and the bishop to
f7 nice to f1 a preparing to further
develop the knight but if I'd replace f4
and I it's enough to look at this
position to see what a beast a von
Schuch was white is up a pawn but but
I'm sure he's not really proud of it I
mean this night isn't going anywhere he
can't go to g3 he can't go to e3 he
can't go to d2 and then e 4 or c4 this
night isn't going anywhere and with f4
this Bishop is completely locked in so
how do you develop here as white it's
it's nothing not an easy task comes get
right Bishop to d2 and he says well if I
can't do anything I will at least double
up my rooks on the e-file we have Queen
to d7 rook 81 now doubling up and a5 he
eventually wants the pressure White's
position even further with a 4 we have a
3 now a for Queen to d1 and Bishop to g6
but even without this Bishop to g6 move
if you look in this position I mean come
she does have doubled rooks on the
e-file but
this rope cannot go anywhere it can go
to e3 e4 e5 all of the squares are
covered and he doesn't doesn't really
have a move if I'd replace Bishop to g6
he wants to improve the position of this
Bishop as it wasn't that strong and f7
but it will be very strong on f5 it will
cut both this way in this way and it
seems like he von Schuch is allowing
come ski to play something like rook to
e6 maybe activating one of his rooks but
after Bishop to f5
this is improving the bishops position
for free and this rook simply has to go
back to e2 and well it's the same
position only one choice Bishop seems to
have teleported from f7 to f5 so this
this would be terrible for white so
after Bishop to g6 we have Bishop to c1
probably a waiting move and not allowing
divine choke any tactics with Bishop to
d3 improving the position of the bishop
even further so Bishop to c1 and out
rook to f7 we have h3 probably again a
waiting move and also making room for
the night and h2 to maybe be able to
develop on g4 Bishop to a5 eventually
improves the position of the bishop
Knight to h2 and or I mean Chomsky is
hoping to play Knight to g4 to achieve
at least something if this Knight jumps
to g4 and then to e5 then maybe maybe he
would be able to do something but he won
Chuck says no you don't and pushes h5 so
the knight is this is a very sad night
rook the f2 probably another waiting
move rook a to f8 night to f1 now rook
to f6 in one chip is pretty much doing
whatever he wants here he will consider
maybe playing rock to g6 attacking on
the G file or or anything really Knight
back to h2 there really isn't anything
better King to h8 by vine Chuck who
knows why he played this problem
probably to provoke young Kamsky to do
something something unsound and well in
fact Kamsky does this he plays b3
he wants to try something he would like
to like to open up the position a bit at
least on the queenside to get at least
some activity but if I should
immediately realizes what a huge blunder
this B 3 move was and eventual plan is
next now event will transfer these
double groups from the F file to the C
file this rook here and this rook here
so rook to c8 as now this C pawn is weak
because v3 was played Bishop to b2
defending the C pawn and we have King to
h7 improving the position of the King
first as the white doesn't really have a
move to play I want you can pretty much
set up the position anyway he likes
before he does what he plans to do
Knight back to F 1 we have rook F to f8
preparing that rook to also go to the C
file rook F to e to doubling up now rook
to c7 Knight back to h2 this night is
very very sad event replace rook F the
c8 now doubling up on the C file and the
night goes back to f1 because Kamsky is
also thinking I mean ok what is this
event you guy doing he's doubling group
rooks on the C file and my bishop is
protecting c3 what's well what's he
gonna do
but even Chuck finds finds a way he
plays B for a bunch of sacrifices
another pawn to blast open the position
a capture some before was played and now
a3 inviting this bishop to capture to
capture an a3 so event you can play rook
captures on c3 and he does come ski
plays Bishop captures an a3 an
interesting way would be if comes he
played Bishop to a1 but this allows if I
took a very very interesting gameplay
with rook captures on c3 sacrificing the
exchange and creating that amazingly
strong passed pawn D a pawn Bishop
captures rook captures and after a move
like rook to e8 Queen to a7 preparing to
push the pawn and also pressuring this
the
or pawn and after something like rook to
d8 bishop character son before rocky
after sandy file and rook to e3 with an
attack on the Queen with an attack on
the rook also preparing to push the pawn
threatening this d4 pawn this would be
completely crushing crushing for black
so after a three come ski decided not to
go for this he played Bishop captures on
a3 and rook captures on c3 was played
and now avenge of doubled rooks and the
C file are well are very strong King to
h2 we have rook rook to e8 attacking the
bishop on a3 Bishop to b2 with an attack
on the rook now rook to d3 with a temple
on the Queen Queen 2 c1
now rook the c8 again with a temple on
the Queen rook to c2 rook captures Queen
captures and well it's very hard to
believe that in this position event you
didn't play the best move which is a
pretty simple tactic actually if I
played Bishop to g6 to give this bishop
further protection but the bishop was
actually protected by the Queen and d7
so event you could have easily played
here rook captures on f3 destroying this
King's defenses and opening up an attack
on the Queen but for some reason we
eventually did see this but he didn't
find a way how to continue this but I
don't think it's that hard to continue
this attack I mean now this F pawn can
move after rook moves this Bishop
becomes alive this would have been
amazing but ok if I didn't play the
strongest move after Queen to c2 he
played Bishop to g6 now consolidating
still threatening all sorts of
discoveries after the rook moves Queen
to F to bishops capture some before now
with a tempo on the rook rook to e5 we
have rook to d1
Queen to e2 and now rook the b1 now
harassing this Bishop on b2
we have rook the rook to g5 and Queen to
c6
rook goes back to e5 and now Queen to c2
Avon shop is offering a trade of Queens
but also he's not fearing Chomsky's next
move which is well it took some
calculation but it's no problem for a
vine choke comes to play the rook
captures on h5 the rook cannot be
captured if you capture the rook avenge
closes the Queen and would check this
would be pretty terrible
so after rook to h5 eventual Conley goes
rook to King to g8 and well now you're
comes this rook is attacked on h5 the
bishop here is attacked twice what's he
gonna do only move that prolongs this
somehow well he does Queen to e6 with
check bishop two blocks and we have
worked to h8 as well no one remove
really helps come see here King captures
Queen captures on f7 and well this this
would have been a great opportunity for
eventual to blunder the game as well
Chomsky is leaving him with some options
he can play rook captures on f1 him play
rook capture some be to him play Queen
capture some b2 and if in fact if I
don't you play something like Queen
captures on b2 this game would have
ended in a draw because now after Queen
h5 there is no escaping perpetual check
King GA - Queen captures an b5 King f8
Queen f5 King g8 Queen d5 King back
Queen back and if you play something
like King d8 then you get Queen at the
b5 check and now if you go to a dark
square the Queen will capture the bishop
would check if you go back to the light
square or yeah
for example f7 then Queen back to f5 and
there is no escaping perpetual check you
can try this for yourselves if you want
so after Queen to f7 even shook of
course doesn't blunder the game away he
plays Queen to c6 now preparing Queen to
h6 if any checks are given Bishop to c3
was played also again trying to give you
a bunch of a chance to blunder with
Queen captures and c3 but this wouldn't
allow a draw if Queen captures on c3 the
Queen would now be protecting
worship on before and this would be
still winning buddy when she played
Queen to c6 Bishop captures on Syria was
played Queen to f8 King to h7 and now
after Queen to f5 check Queen to g6
blocking the check and in this position
the seventeen-year-old Graham has to
resign the game as I mean there is
nothing to do here he was hoping to
maybe grab the rook if if I should play
something else but after Queen g6 there
is simply nothing to hope for here and
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it this was round 4 so again
sorry about that in the previous video I
said that before facing on and he only
defeated Kasparov and Karpov but he
defeated Kasparov Karpov and Kamsky now
in round 4 and well I hope you enjoyed
the game and like I don't think I was
ever sorry for any piece like this poor
knight that comes he hell I do hope you
enjoyed this as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon and
oh yeah my channel did hit 40,000
subscribers today so I will try and
maybe do a tournament or two over the
weekend I didn't do so much streaming
lately because my internet provider
really sucked and well the last two
tournaments I had were really lagging
and the string got disconnected a couple
of times so I fixed my internet provider
now I mean I didn't fix it I changed it
so I think it should be better now so I
will try to make a tournament for
subscribers probably on on Friday and on
Sunday I don't think I'll be able to do
it on Saturday but I will let you know
in tomorrow's video definitely and I
will not be doing a giveaway for 40 40
thousand subscribers I'm saving for for
a nice giveaway when my channel hits
50000 subscribers so yeah again I hope
you enjoyed this video thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon